ça me fait déjà beaucoup très plaisir de
revenir en martinique dans cette île
magnifique et puis je me fais plaisir
aussi bon de retrouver josé que je
connaissais le président des supporters
de saint-etienne
on le voit derrière et puis ça me fait
plaisir aussi de jeu j'espère revoir pas
mal d'anciens joueurs qui j'ai joué
j'avoue que j'ai côtoyés contre qui j'ai
joué voilà et lors de ce tournoi
j'espère à quelques anciens
donc j'espère voir aussi gérard gerland
lyon avec qui j'ai joué bien sûr mais
que je vois c'est régulièrement lui
parce qu'il revient en france
en métropole selon toi martinique c'est
quand même c'est une île aussi où le
football est roi c'est quand même le
sport roi
c'est populaire voilà et il ya eu
tellement de joueurs martinique et qui
ont qui ont fait des grandes carrières
qui voit là et je suis certes il ya
maintenant au niveau des jeunes
faisaient moins maintenant mais je suis
sûr qu'à de très bons joueurs en devenir
aussi ça la force du football
martiniquais
la force du film est impliqué c'est
c'est les jeunes qui vont arriver à moi
ce que je conseille aux jeunes c'est
qu'il faut jouer au football pas pour
les mauvaises raisons
c'est à dire pas pour l'argent parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent dans le
football
forêt joue au football pour se faire
plaisir et c'est ce qui est la jeunesse
c'est ça quand on est un gamin c'est le
plaisir avant tout et après vient la
réussite parce que c'est un sélectif le
pour devenir joueur professionnel
mais c'est le plaisir avant tout faire
s'amuser sur un terrain et moi ce qui me
gêne ce que j'aime c'est les grands
joueurs comme messi comme même gildan
c'est des joueurs qui ont fait on a eu
des crises très grande carrière
mais justement qu'ils savaient que l'on
sent qu'ils sont plaisir sur un terrain
qui leur passion et c'est ça le plus
important
gardé cette passion